i love you
i love you passionately
genuinely and wholeheartedly
like these are like more like happy
tears i mean that was hard i don't
really say stuff like that out loud
oh man
she'd be like i knew you liked me
i don't know if she knew i like loved
her i'm gonna take a picture right now
hey so super random
all right i sent it hey everyone today
i'm here at the park and i'm inviting
strangers to sit here and write a love
letter to someone that they are either
currently or were in the past secretly
in love with after they write the letter
they have the option of either sending
the letter to the person that it's
written to by selecting the envelope
that says lover or they have the option
of leaving it for another stranger to
read by selecting the envelope that says
stranger let's get started is there
anyone in your life currently or maybe
in the past who you were in love with
but didn't tell them
yes
yes
yes actually yes currently i'm
i'm
in love with someone what are you scared
of
uh
expressing myself and
kind of worried i might scare them away
so the next step here is would you be
willing to take your time and write them
a love letter
oh that's tough
i think i can i think i can
write about someone yeah
okay yeah
write it in here yeah write it in there
so it's like as if i'm writing to him
yes exactly
i'm shaking like this is so intense
is this going to be public like this
letter
it might be so that it depends on the
next step okay all right i'll say dear
this was the first love of my life i
would say
[Music]
so how do you feel after writing that
[Music]
um
i don't know i still
still feel like it's
a secret but i mean
it's written down so
it's like if he find if he ever finds it
then there it is
how do you feel
better i was a how do you feel after
writing it
i feel like it's probably been too long
you know what i mean like i feel like
it's been a long time since i've thought
about her but
bringing back memories you know
definitely like opened up some old
wounds a little bit
i mean it was like
two years of like being friend zoned by
this person and me like pining after her
you know it was a long time it set the
tone for a lot of future
heartbreaking
relationships but uh
but i learned so much yeah i really did
that was
a lot okay do you feel a little
emotional right now yes
he was my first like love so it's like
it's very emotional because i'm like
i put a lot of myself into it
so
knowing i like put everything into it it
didn't work out it was like
you weren't good enough like
to that person
and um
even though that's completely not true
you just like put your all into someone
who didn't deserve it in that place and
now like how much i've grown it's like
like these are like more like happy
tears because i'm like
like
i'm so much better
no but
i'm just thinking about it like now
it's like
i was so invested in you and i thought
like
we had forever but we didn't i'm glad
that like we had that short time
together but it still sucks because
of how much an impact that person like
made on like to me yeah and um
yeah it's just emotional
i feel good i haven't really thought
about this
because
like they're not available so i've been
really i'm trying to not think about
them and like and what it would be like
to be together
so now you'll notice that there's two
stacks of envelopes on your table one of
them says lover one of them says
stranger and here's where you decide if
you choose love or you're you're going
to give them the letter
but if you don't want to do that then
you choose stranger in which case you're
going to leave your letter for a
stranger to read and i'm going to hand
you a letter that a stranger wrote
before you oh and you read that to us
[Laughter]
oh
are you gonna mail it to him or
no
okay oh man i don't know
i don't know
how do you think she would react if you
sent it to her
she'd be shocked i think
she'd be like i knew you liked me
i don't know if she knew i like loved
her so one of them says love and the
other one says stranger if you choose
lover that means that you want to send
this to him
uh no
yeah i'm going to put it in the stranger
okay i'm cool oh i don't want to sit too
many years
which one would you prefer
nah i'll give this to her you'll give it
to her
in person are you going to send it
i'm not giving it to a person i will
definitely send it you have her address
i do okay there you go i do do you have
her contact i do actually oh that's
tough
oh [ __ ]
or you could hand it to him the whole
idea is like you just make the decision
here
yeah there goes my bravery uh
[Music]
uh i guess this one
[Applause]
all right before you put it in would you
be down to also read it to us
are you willing to read it to us
okay okay
okay take your time
this is hilarious all right
i'm ready ready is a strong word
okay his name starts with the j
okay
oh my god okay i'm gonna cry now hold on
okay
okay
dear jay
these past few months have been
extremely magical
i absolutely love spending time with you
you treat me like i'm more than special
i have something to tell you that i've
been too chicken to tell you
[Music]
i love you
i love you passionately
genuinely and wholeheartedly
and i hope i hope for the very best in
our possible future together
love olivia
[Music]
every night i dream of you and i
i've seen you grow
and your love has been a raft and a
raging abyss that is my life
you are my definition of love you are
the reason i made promises to god to be
the best version of myself
but now that our time has passed i fear
specters will haunt my dreams of what
could have been
so i wish you love life and the
happiness that you truly deserve
one that leaves you breathless exhausted
satisfied and satiated
a love like you have given me
you heard the earth the oath that i sing
to the stars and that will always remain
true
so please claim your kingdom and walk
this earth as the goddess that you are
you will always find me where i always
am
forever in your heart and in the stars
watching over you as you sleep
in this life and the next
love cole
[Music]
all right dear
you probably knew this at the time but i
was madly in love with you i didn't have
the courage to tell you because deep
down i knew you didn't feel the same way
there were moments when you would be
affectionate towards me and those times
became an absolute addiction
i craved more but the more i wanted the
more you pulled away
it was painful to hear you talk about
the older guys you were attracted to
i was completely and utterly in the
friend zone but i was too young and
naive to walk away
[Music]
i wish then i told you how i truly felt
but i learned so much either way i truly
wish you the best love jake
[Music]
ah man that was hard now that part was
hard
oh man
what are the odds
i normally don't say stuff like that out
loud
i normally like i will write it i would
keep it to myself but like to say that
out loud in front of people especially
in front of my bro like nah
well now that was good though thank you
i'm gonna know when she get this cause
she gonna call me
so is there a chance that like you're
gonna end up with this girl
i would say
like a 5 chance is it a 5 chance because
of her side or your side i would say is
more so for her life path and my life
path is not
romantically compatible probably not
maybe not in this timeline anyway
okay cool and then you know so i could
send this yeah yeah all right there you
go
i'm gonna do this like right now i'm
gonna like take a picture of it send
i'll do it right now if you if you wanna
just wait
yeah i mean i might i mean i probably
won't forget but might as well i might
change my mind is what i'm as i'm saying
so
i'm gonna say i'm gonna take a picture
right now
all right
[Music]
i'm kind of nervous all right i sent it
yeah live
did it live baby let's go
yeah i think i'll pass on the the
writing the letter but i'm happy to read
one so
dear someone dear you dear reflection to
the woman i once loved my dear secret
woman my one and only love of my life
although you do not know that you are
the first time i met you i knew there
she is
a seed was planted a seed of inspiration
love and energy
but you are running in a different field
shopping in a different store
swimming in another lake so i get
pour my heart out and in this poem and
it will in my heart be forever yours
i loved you too early or maybe too late
you in this lifetime was never my fate
i treasure you darling and surely i pray
that next time around you feel the same
way yours forever
i think it's amazing that someone could
so intensely want another person and it
not be returned
or maybe it was returned at one point
but now it's not but
so much yearning i think it's sweet
i don't know yeah
i guess i can't understand because
that's kind of how i was after my
relationship ended and when i wasn't
expecting it to um but yeah no i
i get this
this reaching for someone that is not
there and that is
it hurts
although it's been 20 years since we
last met i can still smell your perfume
on my body when i rested my head on your
shoulder it felt like the most secure
place in the world as if nothing can
harm me
i knew then that it was too good to be
true and we could never be together
forever but i was thankful that i got to
spend all those moments with you
i know you're safe in some part of the
world i know you are happy i look at
your pictures on social media
seeing you with age with time makes me
feel like i'm living life with you
i never thought anyone could love
someone so deeply despite being apart
but i do and nothing really matters not
even distance
call me crazy but i even love the people
you're with now i'm so blessed to have
known you to have loved you not many
people get to love someone like that
[Music]
my dearest love i write to you today
with the heart heavy and aching
i write what for years i could not bring
to my tongue i have loved you helplessly
since the first time you smiled at me
your hand and mine is all i have yearned
for
i have gone to the mosque not to meet
god but you
i have stayed hours after class not to
study but to see you
i have prayed all night not for myself
or my family but you
your happiness and your health i have
prayed for a small glimpse of you to see
me
it saddens me that i will only get to
kiss your lips in heaven
i do not need the rivers of honey and
lavish cushions and comfort we are
promised
i just want to be in your arms
i love our faith but your husband and my
husband will never know the bond we had
people saw us and said they are sisters
more than best friends
oh how they were wrong how they didn't
know i died inside for you
i hope actually i imagine that you love
me too
that you imagine me joking with you when
we are alone as i do
it's odd to say but i hope you remember
my perfume
it's selfish to say but my love i am
waiting for you
my husband asked me why sometimes i
randomly get sad
how can i tell him that a small minimal
task i did reminds me of you
how can i tell him that i have loved you
more than myself
please remember me
i will not ask you to love me back
but please know in this world
there's a woman that would leave her
whole world for you
that's really
what makes me so sad
i just
like i kind of know what she means
like being
[Music]
like stuck between religion and like
what you actually feel like
i grew up in a religious household and i
was always kind of like felt like
feelings towards women
were wrong or like feelings that i may
have had towards women were wrong
so it definitely like it kind of hits me
to see
someone else writing about it because
like i know what that feels like
to like have to hide that part of
yourself even if you like
wish you wish anything like that you
could show people that i feel like i
could never be open with my parents
about it
because i know how they feel about it
i don't know
it's definitely it's it's heartbreaking
because
i don't know just no one
deserves to like have to hide who they
love from anyone else
thank you thank you
[Music]
hey everyone for those of you who are
new my name is thoria and i'm the girl
behind the camera make sure to subscribe
and hit the notification bell so you'll
be notified every time i have a new
episode up and follow me on instagram
i'll be posting more on there as always
thank you guys for everything i love you
all and i'll see you next time
[Music]